احمد بالفعل انتقلت الصوره الان وايضا
المشهد الى حيث اللاجئين او عفوا النازحين
وحتى اللاجئين السوريين الذين لم يجدوا
مسكن لهم جراء انهيار مبانيهم التي
انهارت الجراء الزلزال ولا زال بعض بعض
هذه المنازل يتم العمل فيها على استخراج
اما احياء مع استحاله هذا الشيء ولكن الكل
ينتظر معجزه في هذا الموضوع وايضا لانتشال
جثث والانتهاء من هذه العمليه ولكن ايضا
هنالك ايضا عمليه اخرى لهؤلاء النازحين
واللاجئين السوريين الذين اصبحوا بلا ماوى
فبالتالي انتشروا في اماكن كثيره جدا احمد
نتحدث عن مثل هذه الحديقه العامه التي
نتواجد بها حيث كانت مكانا للترفيه مكانا
للنزهه ولكن انقلب الحال الان بعد هذا
الزلزال واصبحت مكانا للسكن هنالك عشرات
الخيام التي
يمينا ويسار هذه الحديقه الكبيره ويسكن
بها الكثير من السكان التركيين وكذلك
السوريين ومختلف الجنسيات التي سقطت
منازلهم ولكن الاتراك بدرجه اولى هم قتلوا
في هذه المنطقه في محاوله
للاستقرار في هذا المكان لحين
هدوء الامور وعوده الامر الى طبيعته ومن
ثم الانتقال الامه على منازلهم واما
الخروج من هذه المدينه بالاضافه الى ذلك
المساعدات في هذه المنطقه لا زالت مستمره
لو ننقل الصوره الى الطرف الاخر من هذه من
هذه الحديقه نستطيع ان نرى
المركز الملك سلمان وكذلك الفرق الاغاثيه
السعوديه حطت رحالها في هذا المكان لتقوم
بخدمه كافه هذه الخيم المنتشره على يمين
الخيم التي رايناها قبل قليل وكذلك هنالك
طرف اخر من الحديقه يتواجد به عشرات الخيم
لتقديم الخدمات الطبيه لهم وكذلك فريق من
المتطوعين الذين يقومون بعمليات اغاثيه
لهم وكذلك مساعدتهم على اي متطلبات
يحتاجونها في هذه الحديقه في الحقيقه تحدث
عن اكثر مما يقارب 20% من السكان خرجوا من
منازلهم
جراء هذا الزلزال بالاضافه الى المنازل
التي هبطت او انهدمت اصلا تحدث عن عشرين
بالمئه هم السكان الذين
خرجوا من منازلهم ومنازلهم ايله للسقوط
وكما تشاهد احمد هنالك عدد من الفرق
الاغاثيه العالميه تعمل في هذا المكان
شاهد فريق من ماليزيا وفريق اخر عربي لا
اعلم من اي دوله الفرق الاغاثيه اتجهت
مباشره الى هذه الاماكن التي يتواجد بها
الاهالي
وينتشر ايضا بها الاطفال كما تشاهد في هذه